here's a friend of mine she doesn't talk
a lot but when she does it's usually
about something interesting so you
better pay attention this kind of
suspicious character over here is
listening in now he can make out what
she's saying
and he gets it and when she notices this
lurker and turns around to chastise him
he knows exactly what she's saying
freeze this is an example of language in
action but what makes this language both
of them are able to speak to and
understand each other using their mouths
ears and brains that ability gets called
language and it's at the heart of a ton
of things worth learning about humans
about communication about science
philosophy logic and much more they're
using that general ability called
language but they're also using a
specific language they're speaking and
hearing English but we don't think that
this language over here English is the
same thing as this ability to speak and
understand over here after all they
could be speaking French or Swahili and
still be using language so what is it
that sets language apart from all these
languages the characteristics of our
human language ability are the subject
of intense debates and here are some of
the questions that get the brawl started
is our ability to speak something we
learned or something we inherited does
it fit snugly in a wider context
alongside body signals emotions or other
social behaviors and even animal
communication or does human language sit
way up here all distinct and elevated
like and how does language relate to
thinking like the kind of everyday
thinking we do when we have a specific
thought like those flowers are really
really red and also the abstract
thinking we do in logic and mathematics
logic and math allow us humans to think
about things more abstractly and
universally instead of just those roses
I can think about all roses or all X's
or even just the variable X so it looks
like language is a tricky concept but
what about languages surely they're
clearer at least
you